the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
right now we're finishing up with this
first unit and I'd like to continue in
this lecture lecture seven with some
final remarks about exponents so so what
I'd like to do is just review something
that I did quickly last time and make a
few philosophical remarks about it I
think that the the steps involved were
maybe a little tricky and so I'd like to
go through it one more time remember
that we were talking about this number a
K which is 1 plus 1 over K to the K
power and what we showed was that the
limit as K goes to infinity of a K was e
so first the first thing that I like to
do is just explain the proof a little
bit more clearly than I did last time
with a little bit less fewer symbols or
at least with this abbreviation of the
symbol here to show you what it was that
we actually did so I'll just remind you
what we did last time and the first
observation was to check rather than the
limit of this function to take the log
first and this is typically what's done
when you have an exponential when you
have an exponent and what we found was
that the limit here was 1 as K goes to
infinity now so last time this is what
we did and I just wanted to be careful
and show you exactly what the next step
is if you exponentiate this fact you
take e to this power that's going to
tend to e to the first power which is
just e all right and then we just
observe that this is the same as a K
right so the basic ingredient here is
that e to the log a is equal to a that's
because
the log function is the inverse of the
exponential function yes question zero
because it's K multiplied by Ln of 1
plus 1 over K as K goes to infinity that
Ln of 1 right which is real so that
wouldn't this the question was wouldn't
the log of this be 0 because a K is
tending to 1 but a K is attending to 1
who said it was K times if you take the
logarithm which is what we did last time
logarithm of a K is indeed K times the
log of 1 plus 1 over K that does not
tend to zero this part of it tends to 0
in this ATAR part tends to infinity and
they balance each other zero times
infinity and we don't really know yet
from this expression in fact we did some
cleverness with limits and derivatives
to figure out this limit and it was a
very subtle thing it turned out to be 1
all right now the thing that I'd like to
say I'm sorry I'm going to I'm going to
erase this aside here but you need to go
back to your notes and remember that
this is what we did last time because I
want to have room for the next comment
that I want to make on this little
blackboard here what we just derived is
this property here but then I made a
claim yesterday and I just want to
emphasize it against Li realize what it
is that we're doing I just reversed the
I looked at this backwards one way you
can think of this as we're evaluating
this limit and getting an answer but all
equality's can be read both directions
and we can write it the other way e
equals the limit as K goes to infinity
of this expression here so that's just
the same thing and if we read it
backwards what we're saying is that this
limit is a formula for e so this is very
typical of mathematics you want to
always reverse your perspective all the
time equations work both ways and in
this case we have two different things
here this e
what we defined is the base which when
you graph eetu the X you get slope one
at zero and then it turns out to be
equal to this limit which we can
calculate numerically if you do this on
your calculators you of course will have
a way of programming in this number and
evaluating it for each K and you'll have
another button available to evaluate
this one so another way of saying it is
that there's a relationship between
these two things and all of calculus is
a matter of getting these relationships
so we can look at these things in
several different ways and indeed that's
what we're going to be doing at least at
the end of today and talking about
derivatives a lot of times when we talk
about derivatives we're trying to look
at them from several perspectives at
once okay
so I have to keep on going with
exponents because I have one loose end
one loose end that I did not cover yet
there's one very important formula
that's left and it's the derivative of
the powers we actually didn't do this
well we did it for rational numbers R so
this is the formula here but now let me
sorry let's just stick this in here this
is going to we're going to check this
for all real numbers R so including all
the irrational in ones as well this is
also good practice for using base E and
using logarithmic differentiation so so
let me do this by our two methods that
we can use to handle exponent
exponential type problems so method one
was base e so if I just rewrite this
base e again that's this formula over
here X to the r is equal to e to the log
X to the power R which is e to the R log
X ok so now I can differentiate this so
I get that
d by DX X to the our now I'm going to
I'm going to use prime notation because
I don't want to keep on writing that D
by DX here e to the R log X Prime and
now what I can do is I can use the chain
rule
alright the chain rule says that it's
the derivative of this times the
derivative of the of the function so the
derivative of the exponential is just
itself and the derivative of this guy
here well I'll write it out once it's R
log X Prime
so what's that equal to well each of the
R log X is just X to the R and this
derivative here is well the derivative
of R is zero
right this is a constant factor just
factors out and log X now has derivative
what's the derivative of log X 1 over X
so this is going to be times R over X
and now we rewrite it in the customary
form which is R we put the R in front or
X to the R minus 1 ok so this is this is
the I've just derived the formula for
you and it didn't mount now matter
whether R was rational or irrational
it's the same proof ok so now I have to
show you how method two works as well so
let's do method two which we call log
logarithmic differentiation and so here
I'll use a symbol say u 4x to the r and
then i'll take its logarithm
that's our log X and now I differentiate
it I'll leave that in the middle because
I want to remember the key property of
logarithmic differentiation but first
I'll differentiate it later on what I'm
going to use is if this is the same as u
prime over u this is one way of
evaluating the logarithmic derivative
and then the other is to differentiate
the explicit function that we have over
here and that is just as we said
are over X so now I multiply through and
I get u prime is equal to u times R
divided by X which is just X to the R R
over X which is just what we did before
it's our X to the R minus 1 again you
can now see by comparing these two
pieces of arithmetic that there it was
basically the same pretty much every
time you convert to base E or you do
logarithmic differentiation it will
amount to the same thing provided you
don't get mixed up you generally have to
introduce a new symbol here on the other
hand you have you're dealing with with
exponents there it's worth it to know
both points of view all right so now I
want to make one last remark before we
finish with exponents and there I'll try
to sell this to you in a lot of ways as
the course goes on but but one thing
that I want to try to emphasize is that
the natural logarithm really is natural
so so I claim that the natural log is
natural and the example that we're going
to use is for this illustration is
economics ok so so let me explain to you
why the log the natural log is the one
that's natural for economics if you are
imagining the price of a stock that you
own goes down by a dollar that's a
totally meaningless statement it depends
on a lot of things in particular it
depends on whether the original price
was a dollar or a hundred dollars so
there's not much meaning to these
absolute numbers it's always the ratios
that matter
so for example
ample I just looked up an hour ago the
foot see that London Exchange closed and
it was down 27.9 which as I said is
pretty meaningless unless you know what
the what the actual total of this index
is and it turns out it was 64 32 so the
change in the price divided by the price
which in this case is twenty seven point
nine divided by 64 32 is what matters
and in this case it happens to be point
four three percent all right that's what
happened today and similarly if you take
the infinitesimally politically small
increments when you're investing in a
stock you would be interested in the
infinitesimal sense you would be
interested in P prime over P the
derivative of P with responded with
McGee Ferengi ation but let me just
emphasize that it has an actual
significance and it's the one that's
used by economists and people who are
modeling prices of things all the time
they never use absolute prices when
they're when they're large swings they
always use a log of the price and
there's no point in using log base 10 or
log base two those give you junk they
give you an extra factor of log two it's
the natural log that that's the obvious
one to use it's completely
straightforward that this is a simpler
expression than using log base ten and
having a factor of log natural log of
ten there which would just mess
everything up alright so this is just
one illustration and lots anything that
has to do with ratios is going to
encounter logarithms all right so that's
pretty much it
that is that's all I want to say for now
anyway there's lots more to say but
we'll be saying when we do applications
of derivatives in the second unit so now
what I'd like to do is is start a review
I'm just going to run through what we
did in this unit I'll tell you
approximately what I expect from you on
the hour test that's coming up tomorrow
and well so let's get started with that
all right so this is a review of unit 1
and I'm going to just put on the board
all of the things that you need to think
about anyway keep in your head
and so there are these they are what are
called general formulas for derivatives
and then there are the specific ones and
let me just remind you what the general
formulas are there's what you do to
differentiate a sum a multiple of a
function the product rule the quotient
rule alright those are those are several
general formulas and then there's one
more which is the chain rule which I'm
going to say just a little bit more
about so the derivative of a function of
a function is the derivative of the
function times the derivative of the
other function so here I've abbreviated
U is U at X all right so this is one of
two ways of writing it the other way is
also one that you can keep in mind and
you might find easier to remember it's
probably a good idea to remember both
formulas and then the last type of
general formula that we
did was implicit differentiation okay so
when you do implicit differentiation you
have an equation and you don't try to
solve for the unknown function you just
put it in its simplest form and you
differentiate so we actually we did this
in a particular for inverses that was a
very very key method for calculating the
inverses of functions and I it's also
true that logarithmic differentiation is
of this type this is a transformation
we're differentiating something else
we're transforming the equation by
taking its logarithm and then
differentiating okay so so there are a
number of different ways this is applied
it can also be it can be applied in any
way these are two of them so maybe in
parentheses this is these are just
examples alright I'll try to give
examples at least a few of these rules
later so now the specific functions that
you know how to differentiate well you
know how to differentiate now X to the
our thanks to what I just did we have
the sine and the cosine function which
you're responsible for knowing what
their derivatives are and then other
trig functions like tan and secant we
generally don't bother with cosecant and
cotangent because everything can be
expressed in terms of these anyway
actually you can really express
everything in terms of sines and cosines
but what you'll find is that it's much
more convenient to remember the
derivatives of these as well so memorize
all of these all right and then we had e
to the X and log X and we had the
inverses of the trig functions which
were these are the two that we did the
arc tangent and the earth-sun all right
so those are the ones you're responsible
for you should have enough time anyway
to work out anything else if you know
these all right so basically the idea is
you have a bunch of special formulas you
have a bunch of general formulas you put
them together and you can generate
pretty much anything okay so let's do a
few examples before going on with the
review
okay so I just I do want to do a few
examples in sort of increasing level of
difficulty and how you would combine
these things together so first of all
you should remember that if you're
differentiating the secant function
that's just oh I just realized I wanted
to say something else before is so
forget that we'll do that in a sec I
wanted to make some general remarks so
so there's one rule that I you discussed
in my absence
which is the chain rule and I do want to
make just a couple of remarks about the
chain rule now to remind you of what it
is and also to present some consequences
so a little bit of extra unchain the
first thing that I want to say is that
we didn't really fully explain why it's
true and I do want to just explain it by
example okay so imagine that you have a
function which is say 10x plus B all
right so why is 10x plus B then
obviously Y is changing 10 times as fast
as B right the issue is this number here
dydx is 10 right and now if X is a
function of something else say T shifted
by some other constant here then the X
DT is 5 now all the chain rule is saying
is that if Y is going ten times as fast
as T I'm sorry is X and X is x is going
five times as fast as T then Y is going
50 times as fast as T and algebraically
all this
means if I plug in and substitute which
is what the composition of the two
functions amounts to ten times five T
plus a plus B and I multiply it out I
get 50 T plus 10 a plus B now these
terms don't matter the constant terms
don't matter the rate is 50 and so the
consequence if we put them together is
that dy DT is 10 times 50 times 5 which
is 50
all right so this is the let's make that
more legible there all right so this is
in a nutshell why the chain rule works
and why these rates multiply the second
thing that I wanted to say about the
chain rule is that it has a few
consequences that make some of the other
rules a little easier to remember or
possibly to avoid the messiest rule in
my humble opinion is the quotient rule
which is kind of a nuisance to remember
and so let me just remind you if you
take just the reciprocal of a function
and you differentiate it there's another
way of looking at this and it's actually
the way that I use so I want to
encourage you to think about it this way
too this is the same as V to the power
minus 1 Prime and now instead of using
the quotient rule which we could have
used we can use the chain rule
here with the function of the power
minus 1 which works by the by the power
law so what is this equal to this is
equal to minus V to the minus 2 times V
prime ok so here I've applied the chain
rather than the quotient and similarly
suppose I wanted to differentiate the
fold derive the full quotient rule well
now this may or may not be easier but
this is one way of remembering what's
going on if you convert it to V are u
times V to the minus 1 and you
differentiate that now I
use the product rule on this of course I
have to use the chain rule and in this
rule as well so what do I get
here I get u Prime the inverse plus U
and then I have to differentiate the V
inverse that's the formula right up here
that's minus V to the minus 2 V Prime
now so that's one way of doing it this
actually explains the funny minus sign
when you differentiate V in the formula
the other formula the other way that we
did it was by putting this over a common
denominator the common denominator was V
squared
all right that's this comes from this v
to the minus 2 and then the second term
is minus UV prime and the first term we
have to multiply by an extra factor of V
because we have a V squared in the
denominator so it's u prime V alright so
this is the quotient rule as we wrote it
down in lecture and this is just another
way of remembering it or deriving it
without remembering it if you just
remember the chain rule and the product
rule okay so you'll you'll find that in
many contexts it's easier to do one or
the other
ok so now I'm ready to to differentiate
the secant and a few such functions so
we'll do some examples here so here's
the secant function and I wanted to use
that formula up there for the reciprocal
this is the way I think of it this is
the cosine function to the power minus
one and so the formula here is just what
it's just minus cosine X to the minus
two x minus sine X all right
and that is so now this is usually
written in a different fashion so that's
why I'm doing this for a reason actually
which is that although there are several
formulas for things with trig functions
there are usually five ways of writing
something so I'm writing this one down
so that you know what the standard way
of presenting it is so what happens here
is we have two minus signs cancelling
and we get sine x over cosine squared X
that's a perfectly acceptable answer but
there's a customary way in which it's
written it's written 1 over cosine X
times sine x over cosine X and then we
get rid of the denominators by rewriting
it in terms of secant and tangent so
secant X tan X so this is the form
that's generally used when you see these
formulas written in textbooks and so you
know you need to watch out because if
you ever want to use this kind of
calculus you'll have to be not be put
off by all the secant some tangents
alright so getting slightly more
complicated how about if we
differentiate the natural log of secant
X okay if you differentiate the natural
log that's just going to be secant X
prime divided by secant X and plugging
in the formula that we had before that's
secant X tan x divided by secant X which
is tan X so this one also has a very
nice form and you might say well you
know this is kind of an ugly function
but the strange thing is that the
natural log was invented before the
exponential by a guy named Napier
exactly in order to evaluate functions
like this these are the functions that
people were cared about a lot
because they were used in navigation you
wanted to multiply sines and cosines
together to do navigation and the
multiplication he encoded using the
logarithm and so these were invented
long before people even knew about
exponents and it was a surprise actually
that it was connected to exponents so
the natural log was invented before the
log base 10 and everything else exactly
for this kind of purpose anyway so this
is a nice function which which was very
important so that your ships wouldn't
crash into the reef and okay so let's
continue here so now there's there's
another kind of function that I want to
discuss to you and these are the kinds
in which there's a choice as to how to
which of these rules to apply and I'll
just give a couple of examples of that
there usually is a better in a worse way
so illustrate that so here's yet another
example and I hope you've seen some of
these before say X to the 10th plus 8 X
to the sixth power all right so it's a
little bit more complicated than what we
had before because there were several
more symbols here
so what should we do at this point
there's one choice which I claim is a
bad idea and that is to expand this out
so this sixth power that's a bad idea
because it's so very long and then your
answer will also be very long it will
fill the entire exam paper for instance
yeah
chain rule that's it we use the chain
rule so fortunately this is relatively
easy using a chain rule we just think of
this box as being the function and we
take six times this guy to the fifth
times the derivative of this guy which
is 10
X to the ninth plus eight and this is
filling us in it's X to the tenth person
8x and that's it so that's all you need
to do to to differentiate things like
this chain rule is very effective yes
for surgery oh that's a good question so
I'm not really willing to answer too
many questions about of the sort what's
going to be on the exam
but this is the exhibit was just asked
is exactly the kind of question that I'm
very happy to answer okay the question
was in what form is what form is an
acceptable answer
now in real life that is a really
serious question
when you ask a computer question and it
gives you five hundred million sheets of
printout it's useless and you really
care what form answers are in an indeed
somebody might really care what this
thing to the sixth power is and then you
would have be forced to discuss things
in terms of that that other functional
form for the purposes of this exam this
is okay form and in fact any correct
form is an OK form
I recommend strongly that you not try to
simplify things unless we tell you to
sometimes it will be to your advantage
to simplify things all right and
sometimes we'll say simplify right but
it that takes a good deal of experience
to know when it's really worth it to
simplify expressions yes
right so the example of turning to this
example the question is what's this
derivative and here's an answer that's
the end of the problem this is the more
customary form but this answer is okay
all right same same same issue that's
exactly the point yes
the question is do you have to show the
work the answer is do you have to show
the work well if I ask you what's d by
DX of secant of x then if you wrote down
this answer or you wrote down this
answer showing no work that would be
acceptable if the question was derive
the formula for this from the formula
for the derivative of the cosine or
something like that then it would not be
acceptable you'd have to carry out this
arithmetic so in other words typically
this this will come up for instance in
wealth this will come up in various
contexts but you just basically have to
follow directions yes the next question
is are you expected to be able to prove
what the derivative of the sine function
is and the short answer to that is yes
so but I will be getting to that when I
when I discuss the rest of the material
here we're we're almost there all right
okay so let me let me just finish these
examples with one last one and then
we'll talk about just this question of
things like the derivative of the sine
function and deriving it so the last
example that I'd like to write down is
the one that I promised you at the in
the first lecture namely to
differentiate e to the X arctangent of X
okay basically you're supposed to be
able to differentiate any function so
this is the one that we mentioned at the
beginning so here it is let's do it so
what is it well it's just equal to right
it's equal to I have to differentiate I
have to use the chain rule it's equal to
the exponential times the derivative of
this expression here
okay that's the chain rule at the first
step and now I have to apply the product
rule here so have e to the X tan inverse
X and I differentiate the first factor
so I get tan inverse X add to it what
happens when I differentiate the second
factor leaving alone the X so that's X
divided by one plus x squared and that's
it
that's the end of the problem wasn't
wasn't that that hard of course it
requires you to remember all of the
rules and a lot of formulas underlying
them so that's consistent with what I
just told you I told you you wanted to
know this I told you you needed to know
this product rule and that you needed to
know the chain rule and I guess there
was one more thing the derivative of e
to the X came into play there so so of
these formulas we used four of them in
this one calculation okay so now what
other things did we talk about in these
in unit 1 so the the main other thing
that we talked about was the the
definition of the derivative and
also there was sort of a goal which was
to get to the meaning of the derivative
so these are the these are the things so
we had we had a couple of ways of
looking at it and or at least a couple
that I'm going to emphasize right now
but first let me remind you what the
formula is the derivative is the limit
as Delta X goes to 0 of f of X plus
Delta X minus f of X divided by Delta X
so that's it and this is certainly going
to be a central focus here and you want
to be able to recognize this formula in
a number of ways so
so how do we use this well one thing we
did was we calculated a bunch of of
these rates of change in fact more or
less they're the ones which are written
right over here this list of functions
here now which one's did we start out
with just straight from the definition
here which of these things there were a
whole bunch of them so we started out
with a function 1 over X we did X to the
N we did sine X
we did cosine X now there was a little
bit of subtlety with sine X and cosine X
we got them using something else we
didn't quite get them all the way we got
them using the case x equals 0 we got
them from the derivative at x equals 0
we got the formulas for the derivatives
of sine and cosine but that was an
argument which involved plugging in sine
X plus Delta X and running through ok so
that's one example we also did a to the
X and that may be it oh yeah I think
that's about it that may be about it
yeah no it isn't ok so let me make a
connection here which you probably
haven't yet made which is that we did it
for UV prime and we also did it for you
over V derivative alright so sorry I
shouldn't I shouldn't write Prime's
because that's not consistent with the
claim there I differentiated the product
I differentiated the quotient using this
same Delta X notation I guess I forgot
that because I wasn't there when it
happened
ok so so look these are the ones that
you do buy this and of course you might
have to reduce them to other things
these involve using something else this
one involves using the slope of this
function at 0 just the way the sine and
the cosine did this one involves the
slopes of the individual functions U and
V and this one also involves the
individual so in other
it doesn't get you all the way through
the end but it expressed in terms of
something simpler right in each of these
cases and I could you know I could go on
we didn't do these in class but you're
certainly eetu the X is a perfectly ok
one on one of the exams I asked you for
one over x squared in other words I'm
not claiming that it's going to be one
on this list but certainly can be any
one of these but we're not going to ask
you to go all the way through to the
beginning in these in these formulas
there are also some fundamental limits
that I certainly want you to know about
and these you can derive in Reverse so I
will describe that now well let's leave
this up
okay so so let me also emphasize the
following thing if you so this I want to
read this backwards now this is the
theme from the very beginning of this
lecture namely if you're given the
function f you can figure out its
derivative by this formula here that is
a formula for this in terms of what's on
the right-hand side on the other hand
you can also use the formula in this
direction and if you know the slope of
something you can figure out what the
limit is for example so I'll use the
letter X here even though it's cheating
maybe I'll call it Delta X so that it's
clearer to you so maybe I'll call it
maybe I'm going to call it u just so
that I'm going to call it u suppose we
look at this limit here well I claim
that you should recognize that this is
the derivative with respect to U of the
function e to the U that u equals zero
which of course we know to be 1 all
right so this is reading this formula in
Reverse it's recognizing that one of
these limits like rewrite this again
here one of these so-called difference
quotient limits is a derivative and
since we know formula for that
derivative we can evaluate it
and lastly there's one other type of
thing which I think you should know well
so I won you do with difference
quotients there are also other formulas
that you want to be able to derive you
want to be able to derive formulas for
by implicit differentiation in other
words you idea is to take whatever
equation you've got and simplify it as
much as possible without requiring
without insisting right without
insisting that you solve for y that's
not necessarily the most appropriate way
to get the rate of change the must
simply much simpler formula is sine Y is
equal to X and then that one is easy to
differentiate implicitly okay
so I should say do this kind of thing
all right so that's a if you like a
typical derivation that you might see
and then there's one last type of
problem that you'll face and it's the
other thing I claim that we discussed
and it goes all the way back to the
first lecture so the last thing that
we'll be talking about is tangent lines
right the geometric point of view of a
derivative and we'll be doing more of
this in the in the next unit so first of
all you'll be expected to be able to
compute tangent lines
okay that's often fairly straightforward
and the second thing is to graph y prime
the derivative of a function okay and
the third thing which I'm going to throw
in here because I regard it in a sort of
a geometric vein although it's got an
analytic aspect to it so this is this is
a picture this is a computation and if
you combine the two together you get
something else so this is to recognize
differentiable functions alright so how
do you do this well we really only have
one way of doing we're going to check
the left and right tangents must be
equal so again this is a property that
you should be familiar with from some of
your exercises and the idea is simply
that if the tangent line exists it's the
same from the right and from the left
okay now I'm going to just do one
example here from this sort of
qualitative sketching skill to give you
an example here and what I'm going to do
is I'm going to draw a graph of a
function like this and what I want to do
underneath is draw the graph of the
derivative so this is the function y
equals f of X and here I'm going to draw
the graph of the function y equals f
prime of x right underneath it
so now let's think about what it's
supposed to look like and the one step
that you need to make in order to do
this is to draw a few tangent lines I'm
just going to draw I'm going to draw one
down here and I'm going to draw one up
here
all right now the tangent lines here
notice that the slope of these tangent
lines they're all positive so everything
I draw down here is going to be in the
upper above the x-axis furthermore as I
go further to the left they get steeper
and steeper so they're getting higher
and higher so the function is coming
down like this all right it starts up
there maybe I'll do it draw it in green
to illustrate the graph here so that's
this function here all right as we get
farther out it's getting flatter and
flatter so it's leveling off but above
the axis like that so one of the things
to emphasize is you should not expect
the derivative to look like the function
it's totally different it's keeping
track at each point of its tangent line
on the other hand you should get some
kind of physical feel for it and we'll
be practicing this more also in the next
unit so let me give you an example of a
function which does exactly this and
it's the function y is equal to log X if
you differentiate it you get Y prime is
equal to 1 over X and this plot above is
roughly speaking the logarithm and this
plot underneath is the function 1 over X
all right we still have time for one
question and so fire away
yeah the question is can you show how
you derive the inverse tangent of X well
so that's in a lecture I'm happy to do
it right now but it's going to take me a
whole two minutes so here's how you do
it y is equal to tan inverse of X and
now this is hopeless to differentiate so
I rewrite it as tan Y is equal to X and
now I have to differentiate that okay so
when I differentiate it I get the
derivative of tan Y with respect to X
with respect to Y so that's 1 over 1
plus y squared times y Prime
so this is the hard step that's the
chain rule and on the left side I get 1
so I'm doing this super fast because we
have 30 seconds left all right but this
is the hard step right here and it needs
for you to know that dy 10 Y is equal to
1 over Oh bad bad bad secant squared I
was ahead of myself so fast so that
could happen to you on an exam that's a
perfect example here okay so so here's
the identity so you need to have known
this in advance all right and that's the
input into this equation so now what we
have is that Y prime is equal to 1 over
secant squared Y okay which is the same
thing as cosine squared Y right now the
last bit of the problem is to rewrite
this in terms of X and that you have to
do with a right triangle if this is X
and this is 1 then the angle is y
because the tangent of Y is X so this
expresses the fact that the tangent of
is X and then the hypotenuse is the
square root of one plus x squared and so
the cosine is one divided by that so
this thing is 1 divided by the square
root of 1 plus x squared the quantity
squared so and then and then the last
little bit here since I'm racing along
is that it's 1 over 1 plus x squared
which I incorrectly wrote over here ok
so good luck on the test see you
tomorrow